a second round pick from 2015 frank
clark traded to the chiefs yesterday by
the seahawks he had the franchise tag in
seattle there had been some talk about a
possible trade it came it went it
returned last week just before the
seahawks signed russell wilson to a
long-term contract as of tuesday the
deal goes down and what happened was and
basically it's it's a very simple deal
frank clark goes to the chiefs chiefs
give up their first round pick this year
and their second round pick next year
one of the two second round picks that
they have it'll be the lowest of two
second round picks because they picked
up 49ers second round pick in the d4
trade there's also a flip-flop of third
round picks this year now they do that
more and more often now chris with these
trades where they feel like they need to
do something some mid-level flip-flop
just like to really create the
impression they've studied this
carefully and it's like a laboratory
experiment it's that last drop out of
the test tube we have to get this just
right the bottom line is it's a one and
a two as a practical matter yeah for
frank clark and this is part of an
effort by the chiefs and consider this
they they traded up in 2017 to get
patrick mahomes they didn't have a first
round pick last year because of that
deal they won't have a first round pick
this year because of frank clark this is
a guy they're going all in with on the
defensive side of the ball to try to
address a huge weakness for a team that
knows how to score points now they have
to figure out how to stop teams from
scoring points yeah that's right and
they're going with a proven commodity is
there what the 29th pick in the nfl
draft they're just going okay we don't
know and i think two things here you
know the first thing is i think they've
started to realize through the draft
evaluations and all that oh we need a
defensive end which i'm sure they knew
that a long time ago but i think what
they really realized is man some of the
difference making defensive ends are not
going to be there at 29. you know i
think you know again there's a lot of
good edge guys in this draft but i think
a majority of them especially the
game-changing ones will be gone and off
the board uh by the time the chiefs pick
at 29. so they went that route and then
they said okay frank clark proven
commodity let's go get him there's
there's a schematical change in kansas
city this year that's what it really
comes down to more than anything you
know they are trying to go big across
the defensive line all the way through
uh as far as big defensive tackles and
maybe a bigger type of defense at end
this year than what they've had the last
few years they were in a 3-4 defense
with bob sutton it was kind of rex ryan
ish right as far as scheme now it's 4-3
steve spagnullo and i think they're just
trying to go bigger more powerful across
the board frank clark that's what he is
as compared to a d4 who's a true edge
250 pound edge rusher flying frank clark
is more in the
265 to 275 type range could play
defensive tackle and third down obvious
passing situations but if you're
watching on tv alex okafor emmanuel ogba
who was like a three-four defensive end
slash outside linebacker big guy uh i
just think you're seeing a a a change in
how they're approaching things on
defense and i'm a fan of what they're
doing so far chief's making some
aggressive moves and i think this was an
awesome move with frank clark
and and there's another side to this
chris that relates to the off-field
considerations frank clark was drafted
by the seahawks in the first draft after
the ray rice debacle for the nfl and
frank clark had an off-field history an
accusation of domestic violence he was
accused of it he pleaded guilty to
disorderly conduct in a plea deal with
prosecutors the police who investigated
the case though disagreed with the
conclusion by prosecutors that clark did
not actually strike his alleged victims
so that was out there
and when the seahawks drafted him they
took a lot of flack for it and they had
to put that fire out over a period of
several days a lot of people were up in
arms that so soon after the ray rice
situation a team would make a guy a
second round pick with that kind of
off-field history and it was the next
year that the chiefs went through a
similar thing when they made tyreke hill
a fifth round pick after everything hill
did and hill pleaded guilty to
assaulting his then pregnant girlfriend
so when you consider hill's presence the
things currently going on with hill
where he's being investigated for
potential child abuse allegations his
child has reportedly been removed from
the home kareem hunt was abruptly cut by
the chiefs last year after video
surfaced of him shoving and kicking a
woman in the hallway of a cleveland
apartment complex now you welcome in
frank clark via trade they are going to
take more heat maybe they think hey
everybody loves the chiefs now we've got
patrick mahomes we're not going to take
the kind of criticism that we would
otherwise but when you consider hunt and
hill
there's no way that this clark thing is
not going to be a big deal well i mean
yes i i guess so hey the kansas city
chiefs have proven they're willing to
take some chances on these type of
football players you know with the frank
clark situation in specific i mean one i
don't love that we're bringing this up
right now i know he's relevant but gosh
we didn't talk about it when they we
franchi they got franchise tagged or
anything like that so
it does bother me but go ahead go ahead
respond it's part of his chris why does
it bother you it's part of his history i
know it's it's an open book it's been
out there and when somebody had the
audacity to bring it up a couple of
years ago he attacked the person on
twitter for bringing it up look you this
is something that is there and is
something that needs to be considered
especially when there's a guy with a
clear history of domestic violence who's
on the chief's roster now who is
currently mired in an investigation that
may result in a fresh allegation of
domestic violence so look i think this
was going to be an issue wherever he
goes but
it's it's definitely going to be an
issue going to kansas city given what
they've had with hunt and hill you're
right i mean people are going to look at
that and go wait what the hell is going
on here why are we collecting these type
of guys now they did the right thing
with kareem hunt and got got you know
rid of that situation almost immediately
once they saw the video and realized
that maybe kareem hunt hadn't been
totally truthful with them in the
situation they cut the cord and that was
it it was all done you know a lot of
these situations and i know this is a
very sensitive subject and i am of
course totally against domestic violence
or anything like that uh i do understand
the guys make mistakes if they do it
more than one time something like that
uh gosh you're a horrible person you
know at the same time when you're a
young kid you do do stupid things
sometimes and who knows what goes down
i'm not trying to make excuses for him
but i also do think like in meeting pete
carroll a few times being around guys
like john schneider you know trusting
the fact that i know they have area
scouts who'd really do their due
diligence on these type of situations
where they might know some of the
intricacies of the situation uh as far
as the details and what really went on
whether with his frank clark where i
don't think john schneider and pete
carroll the type of guys that just go oh
let's bring him in he's so good he's
such a horrible guy but let's bring him
in anyways i don't think they're those
type of guys so there's obviously
something there that they were
comfortable with and the kansas city
chiefs were comfortable with uh but to
your point yes kansas city seems to be
one of the teams in the nfl that's
willing to take more chances on these
guys or these type of situations than
than maybe other teams in football
yeah and and look it's it's it's it's a
look it's a concern for us because the
nfl supposedly has made it a major
concern for them under the personal
conduct policy now there's nothing that
can be done for incidents that happened
before a guy was in the nfl
but any type of a past history can
become an aggravating factor if there's
any incident while a player is a member
of an nfl team and just from a pr
standpoint and all this stuff about
personal conduct policy it's driven by
pr everything the nfl does by way of its
own investigations and imposing
punishment it is all a pr play by the
nfl and it's not necessarily good pr for
one team whoever the team may be to
establish a reputation for collecting
guys with these kinds of issues i
remember thinking the moment that the
chief surfaced as a potential trade
destination for frank clark boy this
this may not be a good idea and they
went through with it and look they're
they're making the conscious choice we
will take the flack we will take the
heat and we will take the risk that
there may be an issue down the road
because we're going to get a great
player out of it but you know what it's
one thing to throw a flyer in round five
on tyreek hill it's another thing to
trade for frank clark and pay him five
years 105 million dollars with 63
million of it guaranteed yeah no you're
right it certainly is and and again
obviously kansas city feels okay about
the situation now correct me if i'm
wrong here mike i didn't look up like
every ounce of his history but there's
been no issues right since he's been in
seattle he's been totally clean there's
been nothing to see so
uh i mean from that standpoint seems
like it's an individual that's maturing
and again
i you know i i get i know let me answer
your question first let me answer your
question here's what happened in may of
2017 right there was an article on
bleacher report regarding clark's
domestic violence arrest in a story
about greg hardy clark took to twitter
and said people like you don't have long
careers in your field i have a job for
you cleaning my fish tanks when your job
is over he later apologized to anyone
who felt offended but it didn't feel
like a heartfelt apology by clark and
there was a little more skirmish on the
back end of it so that was just in 2017.
and uh and again it's not an it's not
it's a far cry from an allegation of
domestic violence but you just have to
wonder does he get it does he understand
that this is part of his history and
there's no running from it and is he
going to get frustrated when he's asked
questions about it and i guarantee you
he's going to be asked questions about
it yeah he is he definitely is
especially going like like you said into
the environment of the kansas city
locker room where it is a little bit of
a hot button topic uh hopefully he's
grown and matured that way yeah i'm sure
he didn't appreciate being thrown back
into the the public view or scope about
this whole situation uh when greg
hardy's name was being brought up and
all of that so again i have a lot of
experiences in the nfl i am again i want
to make it clear totally against
domestic violence and ever laying your
hand on a woman as a grown man i'll just
say this too though mike i've also seen
situations where i've had teammates who
have gotten arrested or troubled where
they are literally getting hit by their
significant other because maybe they
cheated on them or whatever else and
they're protecting themselves or maybe
holding the females hands and then the
police comes and they arrest that guy
because he's a big strong
african-american guy and they just go
whoa he must be the problem they arrest
them i'm not saying that's happened i'm
just throwing possibilities out there
for all those so we can judge this
fairly on both sides i don't know the
whole details of the situations and what
went on in michigan
bottom line is yes he pleaded guilty to
disorderly conduct as a result of that
incident in 2012 he pleaded guilty to
second-degree felony home invasion as
well that's not good has not been
brought up and that hasn't been
mentioned at all but i just mentioned it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports